today we're talking about clean energy
manufacturer spotlight and innovation
through inclusion
i'm ryan and welcome to this week in
cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news
having achieved 100 annual renewable
energy matching every year since 2017
we're now focused on achieving our
moonshot goal of 24 7 carbon free energy
by 2030 by purchasing clean energy
generated from an increasingly diverse
set of technologies to decarbonize grids
across the globe we are pleased to share
that clean energy projects that we sign
over the past few years across belgium
denmark chile and finland are now
operational providing important clean
energy resources to the grids where we
operate and taking us one step closer to
24 7 carbon free energy head to the blog
to learn more
join us on may 5th to hear leading
manufacturers and technology partners
discuss how they transformed operations
and empowered their teams to solve
productivity challenges and build
competitive and sustainable businesses
with google cloud
you will hear from thought leaders how a
data platform data analytics and ai
models can create a solid foundation for
scaling smart factory initiatives and
enable unique optimization models
jim hogan is both the principal
innovation strategist at google cloud
and the vp of accessibility and
technology for google's disability
alliance
being autistic he's faced severe
challenges in finding belonging in the
workplace
this experience fires his passion for
workplace equity on many fronts
it also informs his technical work of
aligning corporate aspirations to the
realities of software architecture
the common thread he says is delivering
outcomes to customers based on the
understanding that belonging is the fuel
of innovation
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the class